[Musique]
je vais à Paris à Oron Brest médecine je
vais à Bordeaux à Brest je vais aller à
Nice à Lyon dans une école de
commerce le monde appartient à cette
jeunesse des centaines de jeunes
bacheliers étaient à l'espace Redl à la
recherche
[Musique]
d'information
vous êtes présent pour bien sûr un
projet de mobilité pour la première fois
pour la plupart d'entre vous vous
trouverez des stands de part et d'autres
chaque année plus d'un millier de jeunes
sont candidats à la mobilité en France
et en Europe et dans cette étape pour
sauter la mer l'enthousiasme se mêle au
frein logistique concernant les bourses
et surtout si pour savoir si mon école
est est remboursable entre guillemets
remboursable ou pas est-ce que c'est
simple de trouver l'information ou pas
oui c'est simple bah particulièrement
avec cette journée là après après il
faut venir les chercher on va pas nous
les donner comme ça mais ça va oui c'est
bien bon je vais partir mais bon faudra
bien accepter au bout d'un moment est-ce
que tu as trouvé des réponses
aujourd'hui euh oui beaucoup des
informations par rapport au cru par
rapport au département aux aides aux
bourses c'était très utile de venir
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut
vraiment savoir à quel P faut à fait
pour avoir les les aides et et tout les
toutes les les personnes qui peuvent
être là pour nous du C c'est assez
compliqué mais est-ce qu'on s'en sort
oui c'est bon c'est bon on a on a les
bonnes personnes avec nous école de
commerce c'est où à l à Lyon vous êtes
vous avez déjà fait votre inscription
sur Net bourse ou donc vous serez
éligible à une bourse chez nous donc ça
c'est cumulable avec la bourse nationale
et en plus si vous avez droit des droits
de scolarité supérieur à 1000 € on peut
participer au droit de scolarité à côté
de ces gestionnaires du département
référent de net bourse une dizaine de
stands des acteurs de la mobilité tel
que le cross la Domme ou encore la
région de quoi donner des réponses et ce
jour-là il y a autant de parents que
d'enfants l'impact n'est pas neutre pour
eux aussi c'est bon mais comme je vous
dis c'est pas évident non plus pour nous
sortir ici pour aller là-bas s'il y
avait ici ça aurait été super mais il y
a pas aujourd'hui on vient chercher les
informations au niveau des bourses au
niveau des aides parce que ça va être
des études en métropole ça va être des
dépenses et des Pras et on essaie de
trouver le maximum d' pour que lui soit
le mieux possible pour ses études de il
a le moins de souci possible à gérer et
que tout soit plus ou moins calé cette
journée permet effectivement de les
rassurer de les guider dans dans le bon
parcours enfin essayer du moins de de
bien faire en sorte que d'avoir les
meilleures réponses possibles pour ces
jeunes mais effectivement c'est donner
prendre en considération surtout ces
parents euh qui voient leurs enfant
partir vers un l'inconnu il existe des
solutions notamment le département à
travers ces différents dispositifs net
bourse des des dispositifs qui
permettent à nos jeunes qui veulent
étudier à Paris des des conditions de
logement bien adaptées la région
effectivement par rapport à la
continuité territoriale par rapport à la
Dom donc vraiment ces institutions là
sont là aujourd'hui pour guider orienter
et faire en sorte que le jeune s'y
retrouve parfaitement cette démarche
pédagogique du département facilite le
parcours de ces jeunes dans leur
première mobilité un processus
accompagné par l'Europe les aides
financières du département sont en
partie financé par l'Union européenne
via le fond social à l'emploi et donc
dans ce cadre-là le département se doit
de montrer comment il fait
l'accompagnement des étudiants afin que
ça ne soit pas juste un guichet
financier sur lequel on é mararge mais
bien un accompagnement global sur un
projet de mobilité selon l'INC à la
Réunion SEP bacheliers sur 10 seraient
candidat à cette mobilité preuve que
lever les freins à un vrai sens cette
première séquence d'information ouvre en
tout cas la porte à de nouvelles
opérations en faveur de ses
[Musique]
usagers